now to this news General Motors once a
bellwether of American manufacturing is
facing outrage after announcing some
tough decisions about its future it
plans to cut thousands of jobs even
though it's profitable the cuts will
affect 15% of the company's white-collar
workers and many high-paying factory
jobs GM may close one Canadian auto
plant and four more in the United States
chairman and CEO Mary Barra said the
move gives GM flexibility to invest in
the future in her words these actions
will increase the long term profit and
cash generation potential of the company
Kris Van Cleave is at a GM dealership in
Vienna Virginia just outside Washington
Chris good morning good morning
Americans preference for SUVs is part of
what's driving GM away from sedans Wall
Street seems to like this move they
closed Wal Mart
excuse me GM stock up about 5% as the
company is trying to get leaner and
pivot to electric vehicles and
autonomous vehicles but the move is
creating a lot of controversy I moved my
family twice for this company and they
do this to me
outraged over General Motors decision to
drop six underperforming sedans came
quick well we don't like it from
President Trump I think you're gonna see
something else happen there but
congressional Republicans today's
announcement was particularly
disappointing and Democrats I'm really
pissed off about the whole thing because
these guys have blatant disregard for
workers in the country the move will
idle five North American plants next
year where the sedans are produced
potentially laying off up to 14,000
employees mostly in the United States
it's devastating what it will do to this
community not just GM the bad thing is
to get this news when a day at the we
come back Thanksgiving it's all about
greed it's all about put more in their
pockets the cuts include 8,000 salary
jobs among them 25% of GM's executives
making it the largest cut back since the
company went bankrupt and was bailed out
by taxpayers during the 2008 financial
crisis GM repaid those loans the
announcement comes as the Trump
administration steel tariffs have cost
the automaker a billion dollars the
jobs have left Ohio the cuts are a
setback for president Trump who made
this promise in Ohio last year we're
gonna get those jobs coming back and
we're gonna fill up those factories or
rip them down and build brand-new ones
but before any plants can close GM must
reach a deal with the United Auto
Workers Union the union is vowing to
fight we call on GM today just as
they've called on all of us over a
decade ago please save our American jobs
lawmakers and the Trump administration
are pledging to pressure GM to keep the
plants open and repurpose them and to
give affected workers opportunities to
apply for other jobs at GM Ford made a
similar move in deciding to drop most of
its sedans that'll happen by 2022 John
Kriss
okay so let's in the face of all this
backlash why exactly again did Mary
Barra decide to make these cuts the CEO
of GM well the marketplace is changing
and so is the demand for vehicles as
autonomous vehicles are coming on the
market here potentially in the next five
years also it takes five to seven years
to develop new vehicles so if you're
gonna make a change even seven years
from now you need to be thinking about
it today those are factors in this
decision absolutely okay so she's
thinking about the future market now
what happens to the workers so these
plants will in GM's words become
unallocated or essentially idle sometime
during 2019 as early as March in one
case another may stay open through most
of 2019 so it'll it'll be a rolling date
coming here in the next few months
unallocated a euphemism you don't want
to hear if you're a worker there Chris
thanks so much